el ritmo de la música de la Banda
militar Emmanuel macron pasa revista a
las tropas de la base aérea de mon
marshan el jefe de estado francés vino a
presentar sus respetos a los soldados y
anunciar Un aumento considerable del
presupuesto para el ejército galo
su solicitud nacional
puedo adelantarles que pediré el
gobierno nacional que dedique un
esfuerzo presupuestario de 400.000
millones de euros en el período
2024-2030
esto supone un tercio más que el
desembolso anterior este año el
presupuesto militar de Francia asciende
a casi 44.000 millones de euros el
objetivo es aumentarlo cada año hasta
alcanzar los 50.000 millones de euros en
2025 es decir el 2% del pib como
recomienda la otan
en Europa la invasión rusa ha empujado a
otros países aumentar sus presupuestos
en defensa Alemania ha anunciado un
fondo especial de 100 mil millones de
euros para modernizar su ejército en
gran parte abandonado desde el final de
la Segunda Guerra Mundial
pero de momento los diputados alemanes
sólo han desbloqueado 13.000 millones de
euros insuficientes para ponerse al día
su presupuesto corresponde actualmente
al 1,4% de su pib los gobiernos belga
danés rumano y sueco también quieren
aumentar su gasto militar al 2% de su
pib Polonia quiere incluso gastar un 3%
este año es decir 20.000 millones de
euros en lugar de los 12.000 actuales de
los 21 países europeos miembros de la
otan Solo siete cumplen con el objetivo
de dedicar al gasto militar el
equivalente al 2% de su pib nacional
entre ellos figuran Grecia Estonia
letonia Polonia Croacia y Eslovaquia que
se muestran en rojo en este mapa en
paralelo en 2021 Rusia aumentó su gasto
militar al 4% de su caída